The families who live here are among the poorest
in Rio de la Plata.
There's not even running water in the wooden
huts they built themselves.
This woman is explaining to Nicolas Wertheimer
that she gets water from a pump and a hose
that extends through the reeds.
The water comes from the Rio de la Plata - but
it's polluted, and poses a health risk.
Nicolas Wertheimer wants to improve the situation
and founded the project 'Agua Segura' to ensure
the local water supply is clean and safe.
Local children are often sick from drinking
contaminated water.
Their mothers have no one to turn to for help.
“Is diarrhea also a problem?”
“Yes, it is...My little one was throwing up, and
was taken to hospital.”
“Did he get antibiotics?”
“No, they didn't give him anything.”
To tackle the problem, Nikolas Wertheimer
is installing a water filter that doesn't
need electricity.
"This is a filter.
Families who drink water from the river can
position it on a wall, fill it up, and the
clean water comes out here.
It needs to collect in a container that's
clean and not contaminated."
"My whole life long, I've dreamt of changing
the world.
I worked in a
hospital as a surgeon and internist, but I
didn't feel I was doing what I'd always dreamt
of.
One day I googled: 'what do you need to change the world', and I came across this clean water technology.
I thought of all the people made sick by contaminated
water, so I made some calls with a view to
introducing it here."
Wertheimer also managed to persuade
the well-known Argentinian TV presenter
Julian Weich to support the project.
"There's a major problem with clean drinking
water in Argentina - and indeed across the world.
Nicolas is addressing the issue not just
because he's a doctor but because he wants
to solve a problem, I trust him.
I believe in him.
We're supporting each other in a bid to find
a solution."
A few hundred families live along this part
of the river.
It can only be reached by water.
Wertheimer spends a lot of time on
the phone sorting things out.
Today he's accompanying some local children
to school.
Julian und Nicolas founded the Agua
Segura initiative in late 2015.
They see themselves as social entrepeneuers.
Children's health is one of their first priorities.
Their digestive systems are more vulnerable
than adults' - they have lower immunity to
parasites in contaminated water.
At school, the children get breakfast and
lunch - and now, clean water too.
"I'm very pleased.
The principal is very committed and always
gives us a warm welcome."
"The device works by itself.
It doesn't need an electricity supply, and
you don't don't need to add chemicals.
The operating principle is the weight of the
water - it flows through pores that are 20
nanometers in diameter, so bacteria, viruses
and parasites are filtered out.
This is clean, safe drinking water."
The filter costs several hundred dollars and
lasts 5 years.
It's financed by donations - and increasingly,
with public money too.
These kids are also taught about water in the
classroom.
They take the lessons they've learnt home
with them.
Slowly but surely, the health issues related
to contiminated drinking water are beginning
to subside in Rio de la Plata.